voudrais tu y avoir un effet de serre
général réchauffement de 2 ou 3 degrés
de de la température de l'atmosphère
une parole visionnaire en 1979 le
volcanologue haroun tazieff annonce déjà
le réchauffement climatique à cause du
réchauffement de 3 degrés de moyenne
suffisent et les années 70 haroun
tazieff multiplie les alertes sur
l'environnement volcanologues et
géologue
ils constatent les bouleversements
écologiques au gré de ses expéditions
est en fait état sur les plateaux télé
1974 c'est le plastique en mai la
pollution gagne le bien le plus précieux
de l'humanité qui est l'eau ou bien la
pollution industrielle en 1981 tous les
produits chimiques ceux des engrais des
pesticides ce2 des matières plastiques
la radioactivité des quantités
d'accidents atroces menace l'humanité
en france comme ailleurs constaté mais
aussi agir contre un monde qu'il craint
de voir disparaître
haroun tazieff misé sur les jeunes
générations les enfants sont étonnamment
sens ils déçoivent l'importance de la
nature que beaucoup d'adultes laisse
tomber réellement haroun tazieff
poursuit son action dans les années 80
en politique il est secrétaire d'état
sous françois mitterrand de 1984 à 1986
et ont fait un constat d'échec quatre
ans plus tard le ministère de
l'environnement est un gadget comme a
été mon plan parce qu'un secrétariat
d'état à la prévention des risques
majeurs récents et gadgets dans les
années 90 même si le géologue poursuit
son combat pour l'environnement
certaines de ses prises de positions
étonne surtout sur le réchauffement
climatique qu'il nie désormais c'est
selon lui une propagande avec des
intérêts économiques
j'ai réfléchi et tout à coup je me suis
aperçu que les arguments disant que
lowe's home était menacée et fo disant
que la terre se réchauffait n'était pas
vrai haroun tazieff est mort en 1998 à
l'âge de
83 ans malgré son changement de position
dans les années 90 le volcanologue nous
a mis la puce à l'oreille sur bien des
maux environnementaux bien avant l'heure
[Musique]